welcome to this video the DES integrate
I am this is this will be difficult um
the disin to greater I don't know it
doesn't have the name in that playing
the deferred steinitz again for a change
yes this is interesting black now can he
can keep the position closed or take I
will take and try to play this position
interesting i think c5 is a movement
knight c6 Queen d7 95 black young is
relying on his bishop pair but of course
my structure is not not perfect g6 or
Bishop is seven maybe just 60 why not
the long diagonal
okay so okay if I go age 6 okay I can
castle at Bishop h6 is failing to
tonight XD form so he cannot play that
move maybe he can never have was just
about saying maybe he can do that just
canceling along him and trying to go for
a quick quick attack one problem of my
position is definitely that the queen is
not good on the aid if I've can happen
at the bishop on b7 as the main issue
it's looking at this this pawn on e4
tricky thinking about Queen to e5 hmmm
maybe Quinn 285 for counter plane
Queenie six have very little counter
play here not good
nice is coming is like this very simple
attacking scheme from the dragon now
it's very difficult to get any sort of
counter play em now ok this is this
proved to be a difficult opening against
a strong player really really bad this
pollution night chicks probably not move
like rook AJ to Sam is possible but he
has also aged six yes so I don't really
know what else check now this is a
problem the King King on his heaven is
not exactly great and this is probably
where I'm heading
hmm
hmm
I need like five moves or something to
get a decent position a group before
King moves rugby aids even then it just
plays b3 and it's better here remarkably
better this position so that's it this
is not how you play again maybe even
Bishop e7 is not great yeah because he
always has a three and he really makes
the bishop here on this diagonal look
totally stupid but okay i'm
experimenting with some openings if if
you do that you're bound to experience
failure at times it's totally normal
okay yeah keenya seven looks like looks
really suicidal them f4 and f5 coming
avoid if I'm also coming now maybe this
year for for for the night for the night
to join a5 a4 hooray yeah it's still
it's still terrible but what can you do
can I hang on for a little bit here at
least
okay yeah he threatens on g6 but still
checks on d5 but I feel like I mean it's
not that I think I'm in good shape but I
thought it could be could have been
worse which probably tells a lot about
my position oh it's my queen trapped
going to deform going to be for her
maybe 92 runs into queen a1 checkmate it
happens to all of us those stupid stinks
so let's take here first yeah says some
some sort of threat I cannot believe
Adam it should be there should be some
devastating move but doing what can I do
I have to play the same take on b3 check
k grab here rupee one kini seven
I don't see a direct win for him at the
moment but that there should be one c4
or something night a for stuff like that
it's not working really okay it's like
hoping for a miracle here anyway just to
hide morning I can take him check nah he
gets he breaks through here immediately
approached with them check so there are
no no tricks or anything yeah his
opening position was just far too bad
night hangs here well it's just it's
just like totally toasted and I have
Travis pie check here great spy check
check yeah and that's it now this was
just a terrible bad position sighing it
really was I mean this is like a
theoretical position but I probably have
to do something along along the lines of
here maybe be sure my 7 m and g 6 is
just weakening a bit too much as
possible it's really yeah they also the
problem is it's so easy to player I mean
he played it really well with this h4 h5
them in any any little chai can play
that
yeah this is this is biding on the on
granite and I really don't have any play
that's just not good maybe g5 here it's
still bad check yeah it's it's it's
getting all the way I just check the hit
the comp a little bit but it's just it's
just a winning winning position all
entrants nothing nothing to do I
probably have to improve yeah but Bishop
e7 or maybe not even play Bishop to be
seven in the first place just put it on
his six or something like that this g6
gives wide already made a tag on the
King side which is not not easy to play
at all okay so thanks for watching